yeah welcome to this video new
five-minute game playing international
master Prince panic from the Netherlands
this is international massively
Hendricks is best known for his his book
move first think later quite a popular
book released last year it also wants
some some awards book of the year and
stuff like that it's quite interesting
so move first thing laters of course a
bit of a catchy title but it's a one
point of the book is to show that
thought processes are not so so yeah I
know methodical very often there you
don't really often analyze like plus
pros and cons of a position and
weaknesses and so on and then you come
to a move sort of logically and very
often it's just that you see the move
and built a concept around it okay so
back to this we've got a pretty weird
position admittedly but this if you look
at the time and i played this rather
quickly and this is because i am i know
it i know'd because i am recommended
exactly this this opening in a video
series for icc about the caro-kann this
is in fact what I recommended against
the Palo boot Bishop g5 it's a very
technical and okay and how do you call
it let's say yeah very untidy all this
but it seems that black is all right
so we should be three the question is
what now Bishop f5 or is there some
other move Queen f5
yeah both look look okay we should I
find a 5s maybe a more straightforward
okay let's play this it's basically a
queen exchange I'm threatening made on
c2 so we cannot move the Queen he
basically needs to take on f2 when I
take his queen so it's some equal
material now I hope to have some play
with maybe rook c8 coming against this
open king and he has slight problems
with this development cannot easily move
the knight to f3 for example because
I've got this 'if I've night now that I
think of it I was thinking if I was
maybe threatening um night before but
now of course this is not not on i can
say i think i can just retreat i have a
nice trick here maybe with Bishop c5 I
was thinking maybe maybe play a 6cm but
it can always drop back to d2 hmm
my phone is ringing need to take that
later so what now just take this
Knight g4 is not possible okay let's
let's take this and now go for this
Bishop c5 business this is to to speed
up by my development need to get the
pieces out if i play too too slowly then
he probably keeps them keeps a pretty
substantial advantage yes but I thought
I have a thought rook c8 and c5 would be
I would be a good okay it's having us
hanging I know but be 50 K rool Bishop
e7 I can also just play Roo Kade and
maybe these six d6 I thought just Kingda
7 but he's got bishop age three wow why
can I not just take this
I don't I don't get it I just take the
pawn why I'm not quite sure maybe he
just clicked this I did was a massa
what's an automatic move where this is a
bit of a shame it was really an
interesting position and these six is
probably wanted to play the sixth and
he's got this smart move activated what
these six looks good I my problem was I
thought just here but he's got this
check and this is really ugly I cannot
play this move it's very very bad and
then probably I need to go here and then
c5 and this this must be good for what
in some way not sure how how good but
it's better for Wyatt may be very very
good yeah um so maybe around here you
can look for for improvements black it's
not not bad here I cannot know a very
interesting suggestion here by the
computer just f5 I didn't think about
this move at all f5 yeah and this is the
kind of move once you see it suggests
that you instantly recognize that it is
good you just anchor this Bishop here
and it is a strong piece on you for and
yeah it's not like black is winning or
something and it says it's just better
than we put in a bag and now I intend to
play six or g6 Bishop out and he needs
to yes a bit of a problem to to get his
pieces developed computer suggests the
smooth
then you go here and then with g6 yeah
this is good I have like black here it's
probably not great or something I mean
not like a big big advantage but it's
it's a playable position for black and I
would rather play black here than white
but maybe a matter of taste this is this
King would somehow make me nervous so
I'm really open this is an interesting
line i made a video serious on icc about
the carroll content i recommended this
line its own kind of a fashionable of
line that has been played lately two
thousand twelve and thirteen yeah thanks
for watching this game